so corona an sich sind wir uns einig ist
ja schon schlimm aber wenn corona umgeht
und gleichzeitig sitzt im weißen haus
dieses hyper nazistische kind gefangen
im körper eines übergewichtigen opfers
das ist wirklich tragisch weil donald
trumps umfragewerte sinken dreht der
mann inzwischen völlig frei das ist
nicht übertrieben er dreht frei das
virus wütet regelrecht in den usa
schlimmer als in jedem anderen land 26
millionen amerikaner haben wir nur fünf
wochen ihren job verloren und die
pressekonferenzen des präsidenten werden
von tag zu tag bizarr gestern zum
beispiel hat er die medizinische
fachwelt mit dieser idee überrascht man
könnte den körper eine große menge licht
zu führen
ultraviolettes licht oder einfach nur
sehr starkes licht
ich möchte dass sie mit den ärzten
sprechen um zu sehen ob licht und hetze
gegen das virus helfen die reagiert
verdutzt nicht als behandlung antwortet
sie doch trump schiebt hinterher
ich glaube es ist gut sich das
anzuschauen sie wissen schon
die sekunde in der der klar wird dass
dein chef offiziell verrückt geworden
ist und dort schwamm war noch lange
nicht fertig der us-präsident sucht nach
lösungen seine ideen dabei immer
eigenwilliger und dann ist da das
desinfektionsmittel es gilt das virus
innerhalb einer minute
vielleicht sollte man auch das
injizieren für mich klingt das interesse
ja total interessant bruder vielleicht
hilft es auch wenn man seinen kopf in
eine friteuse hält einfach alles mal
ausprobieren
trump hat die pandemie wochenlang
kleingeredet und jetzt sind alle anderen
schuld
alle ist wechselt täglich manchmal waren
seine gouverneure schuld mal die vero
vielleicht doch nur der bossanova man
weiß es nicht
seit letzten donnerstag gibt es die
richtlinie seiner regierung für den walk
down schon einen tag später vom
wochenende hat trump bei twitter zum
widerstand gegen genau diesen richtlinie
seiner regierung aufgerufen ja die
bürger sollen ihre bundesstaaten
befreien schreibt da wenn so etwas
schule macht stellen sie sich vor die
bundeskanzlerin würde twittern befreit
bayern und sie würde demonstrationen
gegen den bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten unterstützen
das wiederum fand ich sehr lustig was
stark macht ist überhaupt nicht lustig
nur weil in staaten wie michigan vor
allem hardcore trump fans gegen den
lockdown protestieren bestärkt er diese
menschen noch obwohl deren krude
ansichten nachweislich leben gefährden
[Musik]
wenn die regierung das land nicht wieder
öffnet dann werden es die menschen sein
die es nicht um deine kappe sagt was
anderes mitten in einer globalen
pandemie dicht gedrängt gegen korona
protestieren kann ich auch nackt im
stadtbad gegen exhibitionismus
demonstrieren
neulich mussten millionen durch corona
verarmte amerikaner tage lang auf die
höchst schätzt ihre regierung warten
weil trump unbedingt wollte dass seine
unterschrift auf diese schecks kommt im
dauerwahlkampf modus und da schreibt er
jetzt alles was dringend gebraucht wird
und das dauert halt ist der präsident
alle atemschutzmasken definiert hat
jeder freut sich über ein beatmungsgerät
aber wie viel toller ist eins mit donald
trump autogramm
aktuell sitzt er übrigens im openoffice
und unterschreibt jedes einzelne blatt
klopapier übrigens die letzte bedürftige
die sich über einen scheck mit seinem
namen drauf gefreut hat war
stormy daniels andere geschichte
immerhin haben zwei große us sender zwei
tv anstalten jetzt aufgehört seine
tägliche corona pressekonferenz komplett
live zu zeigen diese unerträgliche
eigenlob dauerwerbesendung vor allem cnn
muss man an dieser stelle mal loben wenn
sie überhaupt noch übertragen dann
ärgern sie den präsidenten mit live
einblendungen wie wütender trump macht
aus einem briefing eine propaganda show
oder tram weigert sich irgendwelche
fehler zuzugeben ja ist doch schön wenn
fernsehen mal so ehrlich ist oder würde
ich mir von meinem zdf auch manchmal
wünschen diese ehrlichkeit aber klar
dafür haben die deutschen medien
wahrscheinlich nicht genug bist nicht
ansatzweise es schade ist wirklich
schade wo beide auf einen sender kann
sich trump auch mitten in der korona
krise immer verlassen
auf seinen geliebten haussender fox news
deren verständnis von kritischen
journalismus ist inzwischen wirklich auf
nordkorea niveau hier echte fox umfrage
rufen sie jetzt an
zu gewinnen gibt es weitere vier jahre
präsident trump
und so leiden die ganzen usa unter
corona die ganzen usa
nein ein kleiner online händler namens
amazon macht gerade das beste geschäft
aller zeiten die menschen bestellen so
viel kram dass ich total überlastete
amazon boden fragen ja ist denn heut
schon weihnachten
es wird geschätzt dass der versandriese
zurzeit mehr als 10.000 dollar umsatz
macht pro sekunde läuft bei amazon also
es sei denn man arbeitet da acht stunden
liefern am tag bis zu 80 verschiedene
haustüren mitten in new york im
epizentrum der pandemie susanna hat
asthma und einer autoimmunkrankheit die
maske ein privatkauf und krankengeld
zahlt amazon in den usa wohl nur wenn
jemand beweisen kann dass er mit corona
infiziert ist angesichts der test
kapazitäten da mehr oder weniger
unmöglich amazon war ja schon vor
corinna extrem mächtig jetzt ist der
konzern auch für deutschland endgültig
systemrelevant ist nicht übertrieben
reden wir drüber mit unserer netz
reporterin larissa hallo larissa
herzlich und ich bin richtig larissa du
hast mal für uns recherchiert wie sehr
amazon von der korona krise profitiert
sehr herr oliver die profitieren wer
weiß was sonst doch die sind fertig
also dann also ich sag mal so der erfolg
von amazon legt phasen besser
tendenziell natürlich daran dass wir
alle sehr beschränkt sind ist ja so weil
wir haben ja ein kontakt beschränkung
das heißt wer raus geht dann muss ein
strafraumeck bezahlt werden die stadt
das neue leute kennenlernen keine ahnung
sie ist wahrscheinlich ja ein sehr
bitterer frau und hass junge menschen
kann ja sein und das problem ist jetzt
aber dass wohl viele von den sogenannten
leben er draußen sind aber genau darin
draußen dafür nicht mehr hin
inzwischen darf man ja schon wieder in
leben
schmiden gedankenfluss denn er ist
gerade wecken also ich sag mal so alles
ist die menschheit braucht also es
besteht dann nur noch im internet
deswegen hat die schneiderin geschäfts
in b und zwar warten will ein online
handel für essen entschieden und das
sind dann die franz land oder so ähnlich
egal
und jetzt dann denken sie wahrscheinlich
jetzt also der laie von corona
profitierte ganze online handel aber
dass es sich so das ist falsch
experten verweisen darauf auch der
online sektor hat probleme also kann man
nicht sagen dass der online-handel jetzt
per se als gewinner aus dieser situation
hervorgehen der einzige der
offensichtlich stark zulegt ist amazon
genau wo amazon weil die deutschen
online food sie machen einen schlimmen
fehler ich schwöre sie zahlen ich hab
das mal recherchiert so genannte steuern
das heißt du meine güte herr oliver sie
können sich das nicht vorstellen den
gehen was ab von dem was sie verdienen
dann hat man weniger ich fand mich an
dieser stelle wirklich wie dunklem
steuern ja da habe ich auch schon von
gehört amazon zaubert tatsächlich mit
absurderweise legalen steuertricks immer
noch seine deutschen gewinne weg das
heißt wir machen unseren einzelhandel
platt und zahlen obendrauf nicht mal
nennenswerte steuern gehen ja aber genau
deswegen ist der amazon boss jeff bezos
auch die reichsten glatze der welt und
corona gewinner number one und two one
heißt die 1 das privatvermögen ist seit
jahresbeginn um 23,6 milliarden dollar
angewachsen auf platz zwei der liste mit
den größten krisengewinnern folgt tesla
gründer elon musk
auf platz drei ist erneut der name
besser zu lesen die ex-frau von jeff
bessers mackenzie bessers bekannten
vergangenen jahr nach der scheidung ein
aktienpaket es kostet heute über 45
milliarden dollar
dabei ist die frau voll alter über 30
kleiner tipp an den deutschen
steuerfahndern wenn ihr geld von jeff
bezos wollt müsst ihr warten so schwer
ist doch nicht ein baby kann das ja also
sie finden das okay was amazon macht
natürlich nicht herr oliver auch ich
mache mir bedenkt tische sorgen um
unseren deutschen einzelhandel und das
können sie jetzt alles nachlesen in
meinem neuen buch warum wir alle nicht
mehr bei amazon kaufen sollten
es ist wirklich ein sehr sehr sehr gutes
buch ich schwöre kauf dass alle der
amazon link sind unten eingeblendet
natürlich wird das unsere netze
reporterin larissa
[Applaus]
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye